I'm here with BuzzFeed, I'm playing with tiny, cute kittens.
My day is made.
We designed for Belle this ring that would sit on her little finger.
The costume designer saw that I had one which my mom had given to me.
And she was like, "Can I design one for Belle...
...because Belle's mother dies when she's really young."
My mom is still alive and healthy and well, just as a side note.
Anyway, I was really proud of the ring and thought it was so beautiful...
...that I asked if I could keep one and they said I could.
Do you want to come down?
Is this a little high for you?
Oh no, you kind of want to stay.
Okay, you go here, you stay there.
I would want her to know that she is a force to be reckoned with...
...and never to underestimate her own power.
Sometimes, particularly, young girls feel like their voice doesn't matter...
...and what they have to say doesn't really matter.
And I think I would want her to know that it does.
Oh, some rose petals look.